des dangers qui êtes trading france
finalement c'est normal monsieur je suis
arménien un col est doré
1 colette renard
jacqueline françois 1 jacqueline boyé
et vous voudriez que ça s'appelle
autrement qu'un pascal souvent monsieur
non
vous êtes
le vieux piano de la plage ne joue qu'en
faire quand fatigué le vieux piano de la
plage possède un là qui n'est pas gay
ainsi cassé qui se désole un lift année
qui le console un doublé par grand
soleil du mois de juillet
mais quand il joue pour moi les airs
anciens que je préfère a pris son
autrefois en force alors dans
l'atmosphère d'un grand bal heures dans
une petite chambre
mon grand amour du mois sept mois oui si
souviennent ses vacances dans finistère
chez sa grand mère c'est pas chez ma
grand mère était avec ma grand-mère le
sud y un petit village du finistère ça
s'est passé j'avais 17 ans ça a été très
bref c'est très joli
je garde un bon souvenir puis après ça
va vite très vite dévié vers le centre
de la france qui sont là mes vraies
vacances d'enfance dans le limousin
après deux traits d'image son limousin
mon limousin alors là c'est le petit
citadin qui jouent aux paysans en
prenant lui nous hein j'aimais beaucoup
les étables j'avais beaucoup les cochons
je vais beaucoup les canards je vais
préparer la pâte et pour les cochons
oui j'aimais beaucoup ça avec mon oncle
il préparait les pommes de terre
ça sentait très bon et on mangeait
l'époque et pommes de terre qu'on
faisait cuire dans la maintenant
j'essaie dans la pâte et les cochons je
me souviens de ça c'est un rituel on
mettait espèce de conserver leur de la
sueur de boire on malaxe et ce avec les
mains j'étais très content que le
cérémonial
et j'ai beaucoup aimé l'infini j'aime la
ville j'ai un bon équilibre avec la
grand pagne et quand je pense à la
campagne c'est forcément la campagne de
mon enfance c'est à dire là et à partir
de l'âge de 10 ans à peu près ça a
commencé à aller dans les bals dans les
bals de campagne
écoutez l'accordéon oui et c'est là que
j'ai appris ce goût pour la peau la
vraie chanson quoi on appelait ça la
frairie ça portait le nom de des fêtes
locales dans dans cette région est en
effet ce dont ça se passait dans les
années 60 quoi et on est privé des
balles très charmant avec des gens qu'on
tanguay j'ai une image de fraternité
d'été avec le son de l'accordéon qui
symbolise pour moi une sorte d'amitié
c'est gentil a dévié de quelle chanson
tu te souviens de l'époque dans ses
balles avec l'accord dès les premières
chansons à l'époque c'était j'ai quitté
mon cherché à détruire corrézien rédac
c'est là mais c'est formidable formule
dès que dès que je peux chanter sale
après midi à la télévision
une fois de temps en temps la france
s'écroule en larmes ou 11 mai de bonheur
c'est bien il nous faut aussi des dix
mois alors après il ya eu bessines où
son père tenait un bar tabac
mon père était élevé wen dans ce bar
tabac mais j'ai vu j'ai vu apparaître là
alors je retournais chez d'attendre
qu'ils avaient élevé mon père et j'ai vu
apparaître le premier tout box donc 59
alors là vraiment c'est tgtu rester
collés devant un an ce qui se passait
c'est que tu es des donc dans le bar et
en échange de quoi tu avais des pièces
de 20 centimes et puis alors tu l'aimés
tu évites dans le jukebox et écoutez
quoi emballer coup à l'époque ont écouté
alors vraiment les toutes premières
chansons de johnny hallyday les bonnes
plein de choses fait que les premières
bons souvenirs souvenirs tout le monde
le sait et françoise hardy
donc la première chose sylvie tous mes
copains
alors je vois ça comme si j'étais on
écoutait aussi les dernières chansons
gloria lasso à l'époque mais oui parce
que c'était c'était très large de
l'ariana et oui moi aussi c'était très
mélangée à l'époque je n'y étais une
jeune beurette loria souhaitait une star
la lydec commencé de très près on
l'écoutait bombe idowu on écoutait les
cloches de lisbonne
on écoutait étrangères au paradis gloria
lasso leurs étrangers au paradis tout
aussi bien dans ma main car je suis
étrangère ici dans ce pays bleu
étrangères au paradis sapin papa papa
fin prêt et vénus venus mon ami
dida
je suivais pas les paroles mais ce
n'était pas génial non il y avait au
venus les compagnons tous l'ont chanté
dis donc physique à l'époque du coucher
avec son transistor
oui on est agressée alors abbas était
sexuellement sexuellement c'est un bon
début
c'est vrai que c'est toi tu as 25 mille
dix bonnes soient mieux que j'ai fait un
peu beaucoup mais en tout cas entre 15
et 20 milles sur wii et alors tous ses
disques
oui tu veux en amener un seul sur une
île déserte elle quelle question
impossible quand on a 15 mille m'enfin
bon impossible je serai peut-être
peut-être une chanson de lucienne delyle
peut être un air d'accordéon de jo
privat une chanson de trenet mais déjà
je suis injuste parce qu'il ya quelque
chose mais je vais oublier ou comme ça
je partage avec renaud legoux pour une
chanson qui s'appelle mon amant de
saint-jean
sachant qu'ils n'aiment pas moi qui il
aime et en ombelles avant mon amant de
saint-jean
un très joli un classique je vais faire
ton éducation ah oui ça va me prendre en
main oui très sérieux écrit pour dalida
il venait d'avoir 18 ans oui ça c'est
pas d'intox mouais ça c'est de l'info à
peine un point c'est quoi les paroles
exactement il venait d'avoir 18 ans il
était beau comme un enfant fort comme un
homme s'est elle était évidemment j'ai
compté en le voyant mes nuits d'automne
j'ai mis de l'ordre à mes cheveux un peu
plus de noirs sur mes yeux ça la fait
rire quand il s'est approché de moi
j'aurais donné n'importe quoi pour le
séduire ça finit tristement parce
qu'elle s'aperçoit qu'à la 2 x 18 et
c'est quelqu'un de très bien connu le
héros de la chanson au lieu à l'époque
oui oui sûrement
vidéo c'est vrai que ton premier job de
vacances c'était garçon coiffeur je n'y
crois pas absolument
mais tu sais quand on a 15 ans comme ça
et qu'on dit à sa mère et à son père
qu'on veut être écrivain chanteur tarder
je ne sais quoi on vous dit il vaut
mieux apprendre un métier et ma mère qui
n'est pas stupide m'a dit que ce serait
peut-être bien que tu coiffe les
voisines et après la plus un métier et
c'était patron du tout parce que ça m'a
beaucoup servi notamment sur ce
militaire ah bon ça t'a permis de la
valeur garde du général
ah bah oui c'était dix années alors je
m'étais bien l'arranger s'il se souvient
de ces aimants de vacances où il force
eu forcément mais mes grands souvenirs
et ça va être terrible pour toi ne sont
pas sexuel alias et je sais je suis un
peu mais je sais